some very good news this is a story from
Fox Business Target loses 9 billion
dollars amid Pride merchandising
controversy Target stock is experiencing
its worst six day stretch since the six
days ending May 25th and not only that
Bud Lights uh at anheuser-busch's stock
hasn't they've wiped out all their gains
from the year so far they're now down
for the year fantastic this is the Bud
Light effect it was the Catalyst Bud
Light was the easiest thing to boycott
for anybody and they did near 30 percent
sales dropped now Target is scared
saying uh oh we don't want to end up
like Bud Light the fear now is this
social social effect where the people
who held on to their Anheuser-Busch
stock because they were assured by the
media don't worry these things will
fizzle out they've lost a lot of money a
lot I think it's like 12 or 13 percent
now if you're hearing this so you
experienced that a month ago you're like
I got my anaz or bush stock at 60 65
bucks I'm not worried about it now it's
at you know 50 something I don't know
where it's at you're going okay I just
lost a ton of money this I can't let
this happen again so people are probably
gonna start selling off more and more
Anheuser-Busch stock because the price
is going down it's become a cell not a
whole not a buy Target then becomes the
subject of controversy if you just lost
a ton of money on Anheuser-Busch stock
and you're sitting there seeing the news
I'm assuming a lot of these people say
nope I am selling right now I don't need
to hold on a Target I could hold on to
any other stock I'll buy Apple I'll buy
Tesla I'm moving my money boom stock
starts dropping then it creates a
Cascade effect where other people go
they call it their their you know broker
or they call up their uh wealth
management manager or whatever and say
why why is why is my portfolio going
down and say oh well Target just
suffered a major drop off we'll sell
sell why are we in it why are we in
Target right now how many people are now
not it's it's not even an impact of the
boycott it's an impact of
if there is fear in the in the public
that a stock will drop due to boycott
that will be a self-fulfilling prophecy
the Bud Light effect if you go woke your
stock will drop people are going to
start selling off and if you don't you
will be the one holding the empty bag
and that's the sentiment where people go
not going to be me without potato I'm
there's there's a billion other stocks
to buy nobody cares about Target Target
stock so while it's not so easy to
boycott a big box store like Target if
it's the only one in your neighborhood
it's really easy to buy a different
stock to put your money very easy very
easy that's what I think we're seeing
that's what I think what we may we may
be seeing that now and Target's 100
reinforcing what you're saying they are
just as Panic they're quietly moving
things off their web website while
seeing these reports of some stores
being told to relocate their merchandise
uh they had that collaboration with uh I
think it's called uh abharlin it's the
UK he says he's not a he says he's not a
Satanist by the way but it's this guy
named Eric Carnell the shirt yeah he
says he's not he just makes some fun
Satanist merchandise
gay trans identifying designer
so I wrote this story about Target a
couple days ago I was checking out some
of this person's merchandising uh and I
noticed that Eric Carnell's stuff today
has been moved off the Target website
this person has also closed his Etsy and
his store front and has pulled posts
from social media that were like
basically anti-cis they had like
lighters that said burn the system down
CIS super cool a homophobic headrest and
it's a guillotine and in the if you can
find this stuff on Twitter still people
people grab the screenshots uh all of
these comments that are basically like
we need to destroy this system it's not
enough to just ask or be accepted we
have to dismantle what's there very
radical kind of semi-calls for violence
and it's it's a really interesting time
where Target panicked and so this person
panicked and you can see the effect now
now he's destroying Target right not the
whole system I I don't know I mean in
some ways he's a catalyst well and then
Reuters ran this article that was like
uh this UK designer the clever Target is
seeing a rise in sales and that that's
why he closed his website I don't think
that's true I just want to put that out
on air right now
rubbing his stuff to make sure anything
that is deemed controversial or radical
is off now that you might be able to
capitalize on sympathetic leftist
dollars or or stop trying to groom our
children
um
or just don't do that the culture War
elements of this are less important than
a monetary elements of this I I agree
there's going to be I'm imagining it
some there's a young wealth management
wealth manager guy he's managing some
portfolios for some people they get on
the phone he goes look I'm going to
recommend against Target stock uh
there's some controversy going on I
don't know a whole lot about it but it's
probably risky let's move you over to
something safer maybe we'll put you over
here somewhere else right yeah I mean I
don't know why I don't just start
shorting these stocks as soon as these
stories break
that is not Financial advice
give that on this shot we're very
careful about Not Giving that advice in
years past this type of panic hasn't
been that effective right like we saw a
slow burn after the Cutie stuff on
Netflix people being like I'm leaving
Netflix and they did see some trouble it
wasn't as dramatic as the Bud Light
issue but right now this has really hit
a nerve and to follow so quickly after
that you can see people feeling more
motivated they saw uh their decision to
boycott having a financial impact maybe
they can do it again they can really
feel like they're making it so I have a
four-year-old daughter I have a
two-year-old daughter and I have a
four-month-old little boy and my wife
was religiously shopping at Target and
if you're telling me that we're selling
bathing suits that allow you to talk
talkable bathing suits to children they
weren't for they weren't for kids no the
children's one say uh thoughtfully made
for the type of body exactly exactly
exactly so it was like it was like a
double entender in that case right they
were condo in both but also I don't even
want my children walking past that stuff
amen right that's this number one so you
worked about ice cream earlier yeah
and uh my kids love ice cream and if I
left it up to them my little daughter
would eat ice cream for breakfast lunch
and dinner so why in God's name would I
allow my child to select her gender at
four five six seven years old before
she's even an adult I don't like the
idea of even even walking our children
in front of this in my anti-trans no
when you're an adult you can do whatever
you want in this country as long as
you're not hurting other people as long
as you're not hurting anybody else and
the fact is my job as the United States
Congressman to keep the federal
government actually out of your life
that's that's what I'm trying to do more
than anything else but for children this
is ridiculous yeah I think real quick I
think what we may be seeing with Target
is that it's not actually a boycott from
conservatives I think this reaction was
so rapid that regular people walked in
and had a very negative reaction like
why is this in front of my kids and
these are not political but so this is
75 25 issue in this country three so
when it's a 75-25 issue that means this
is not a partisan issue this is
literally people being like I might be
liberal but this is insane yeah well the
first time I heard about this was on an
Instagram reels of you know a leftist
you know influencer saying basically
like why are they pandering to us with
this weird Pride stuff they're making
fun of fact that there's like a queer
all your calendar like yeah nobody wants
nobody wants that why did Target do this
they only hurt themselves ESG baby no
they're they're trying to Virtue signal
that's it they want to be true but the
people they're disabling don't like it
they don't want it well I mean and
that's why they have a shirt that says
live laugh lesbian I don't know what
does that even mean I don't know I don't
understand I was like we're gonna win
we're provocative yeah I guess it's
survival
is
they're falling in line with the ESG
stuff if you want funding and financing
yes G is the way to go and then they're
thinking this is what people like the
reason these companies do it is because
they think if this is what's popular
socially this was in Hollywood now that
there is a negative impact and people
saw Bud Light this the Bud Light thing
is a major shift in culture War yeah
because now these companies are going no
that's controversial and you'll lose
money don't do it exactly like it used
to be the case that what it should be
just drink beer yes right yeah I mean it
used to be the case that getting
political was controversial and now it's
been the case that getting political
isn't controversial as long as it's a
left-wing opinion but the left has gone
so far that they're getting back to the
point where leftism is once again
beginning to be seen as controversial
thank goodness thank goodness
there's a good news this is uh this this
is a very optimistic moment for
everybody I think I think we're gonna
start seeing more of these stock
drop-offs we saw with Netflix something
similar maybe a precursor to this when
they lost something like two or two
million how many how many subscribers
they lose it millions of subscribers or
something like that and we don't know
exactly why but a lot of people think it
may be because of the cuties thing
because of big mouth and these other
shows that they're like we don't we
don't want to pay for this I think
Disney is now experiencing a Mabry
user drop off and uh
yeah I I think get well go broke is
starting to become more and more
starting to catch but I think it's
because the left has just gone too far
exactly I think you're right it's not a
conservative issue or it's not it's not
political because when you lose that
many subscribers it there all are
conservatives that are that are that are
subscribed it's actually people that are
parents that are looking at something
and they think to themselves you know I
can't explain to you what what perverted
is but I know it when I see it yeah and
that's what it is and any parent that
cares about their kids that they're
going to protect their their kids from
that exactly the parents are gonna well
like technically uh that doesn't have to
be inherently sexual so we can try to
separate it out yeah I don't know I
don't want this near my kid I think I
think I think it's much much simpler
than that yeah I think the parent turns
on Netflix and is clicking through and
goes
I don't I don't think we should have
this on the TV uh honey because if we
don't want the kids watching it okay
well I'll just cancel I bet they don't
even think that much about it for the
average person life is much simpler than
those of us who are entrenched in
cultures for sure for sure they walk
into Target and they go oh my god let's
go somewhere else
exactly what you're talking about they
don't they look at it on some level of a
register I don't want to have to have
this conversation with my kids it's not
even at the Forefront of the range just
like a repulse and now let's just
separate from it they don't want to be
okay I'm here right now
we're glad you're here too man this is
so good to hear because because I I'm
constantly surrounded by by I think
highly informed people we always get
into these you know these pragmatic
conversations and we go down these
rabbit holes and I think sometimes we
can take a step back in here I I think
the right time to think it is much more
people yeah well because look when I
heard about Target losing all this money
wow I'm like there's no way
conservatives organized a boycott this
effective this quickly no that's
impossible exactly exactly
oxymoronic because there's no way when
they said that there were confrontations
I was like if there were confrontations
it was not because Matt Walsh got on his
show and said we're gonna boycott Bud
Light it's because a regular person with
his four-year-old daughter walked in and
went oh my my God and I don't Daddy
what's a lesbian what where did you see
that it said live laugh lesbian he's
like that's not even Dramatical
don't laugh
maybe a little bit older than four I
don't know what year a lot of these kids
are learning to read but they probably I
don't know if they can read the word
lesbian or even notice it yeah but the
parents probably see these things right
when they walk in and say I don't want
my kid I'm not going to explain to my
four-year-old what these things are
that's a good point we don't have like
these are sexual subjects yes the left
denies but they literally are LGBT is a
reference well LGB is a reference to who
you enjoy engaging in adult activities
with and then they added tea to it which
is transgender which doesn't necessarily
relate to the others that's why there's
been a controversy there but if you're
putting something up right in the front
display being like celebrate who you
have sex with you are now having to
explain to Children what this means and
why and you're like my kids aren't ready
for the birds and the bees talk let
alone LGBT birds and the bees talk you
walk into Target normally what do you
see you see the Easter Bunny you see
Reese's Peanut Butter Cups
dude the way it's going they'll be like
trying to get tell them about like
sodomy and then when you want to talk
about the birds and the bees they're
like they're too young for that like
they can't have this conversation they
they there was uh in these schools when
Rhonda santis started uh Banning these
these uh pornographic books perverted
like they're they're over they're Kink
books
these things are not sexual it's very
important right it's fetish porn they're
uh uh Nikki freed called it butt plug
porn mocking Rhonda santis not realizing
she was proving his point exactly when I
showed this to a lefty friend of mine he
says it's sex ed I said no it's not this
is kink Kink education for children that
that's ridiculous if you think that
is sex ed I don't even want to know what
you think sex is all right okay well
when you take a light bulb and then you
uh eat it up yeah like the the idea it's
not how human beings function this is
not how this is not how man's body was
built to function so now we understand
why homeschooling's on the ride
earmuffs for your kids but I just got to
say this when we make fun of people who
go to the hospital with foreign objects
lodged in their rectums it's because you
can't do that but people defel develop
paraphilias and fetishes where they do
things to their bodies that are damaging
yes we don't want to make people develop
behaviors that are harmful to them and
we want to protect children from these
things why would a school teach a child
about putting foreign objects into their
anus is beyond me but I'm glad Rada
Santa said f that and got rid of it ooh
but it's not Beyond you you know why
they're doing it we know why they're
doing it because they want kids
they're groomers that's it because I'll
say uh Target already came out on the
pride issue a long time ago they sell
like Mr and Mr wedding cards like
they're fine it's this year's specific
push for the transgender gender issue
well that is I think really in enraging
people or maybe bringing attention to an
aspect of all of this that people are
firmly against right well and this is
something conservatives have to remember
when we message this okay the
conversation is not over why do kids
need to see this we know they don't the
question is why do you need kids to see
this why do you need to show this
disgusting fetish porn to Children
what's wrong with you the conversation
has to be about the person who's trying
to show this stuff to kids Democrat
Nikki Freedom Florida called the
material that got banned butt plug porn
exactly yes because she was making fun
of Rhonda Santos and it was like thank
you for proving the whole point yep that
shouldn't be for children not for kids
he was saying this is school and she's
like can you believe he shared this on
Twitter in front of adults it's like
it's being shown to children in schools
you lunatic thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time